>>Teacher: And so,
how are you going
to get from there to there?
>>Student: I think
it's south and west.
>>Teacher: Okay, try it,
like take your finger
and now follow my
finger with me, west.
Do we get to our destination?
>>Student: Yeah.
>>Teacher: All right, high five.
>>Lynda: It's a real challenge
to educators today to figure
out how do you use your
available resources
so that every child succeeds.
>>Lynda: Before we
started our work,
we had what other schools had.
There would be a
teacher in a classroom.
They would teach a curriculum.
And if a student needed extra
help, out the door they went,
down the hallway they went
and somebody else pulled
out all the tricks
that they knew
and tried to teach that child.
So for us, it was really
flipping that whole model upside
down and saying, "These are
the resources we have available
to us.
How do we get everybody working
together to design a system
that is more seamless
for students?"
>>Holly: The system
would not work
without teacher collaboration.
>>Mindi: Every decision we
make, we have to make as a team.
>>Ashley: And we problem
solve together and look
at data together and make
decisions about what kids need.
>>Lynda: If we're going
to work collectively
to ensure the success of every
child, then we had to get
on the same page about
what we were teaching.
So for us, it was
an early lesson
in identifying a core
curriculum in math and reading
that was the same no
matter who the teacher was.
>>Ashley: So every single
student will receive, you know,
universal instruction,
core instruction,
also known as Tier 1.
Some kids will need
supplemental instruction.
They'll need a little
bit more than core.
So you'll hear that
referred to as Tier 2.
And then, some kids may need
more intensive intervention
and so, you'll hear that
referred to as Tier 3.
>>Teacher: So what
did it tell you to do?
How are you going
to figure it out?
>>Ashley: Teachers
at the very beginning
of the block are
teaching core instruction
to their core 22 students.
And then they would
move into a time
that we call autonomous time
where the students will be more
self-directed in their learning.
>>Students: Columbians are--
>>Ashley: So some teachers
may pull Tier 2 at that time.
You also may see Tier 3
being pulled at that time
in a very small room where
kids can really focus.
>>Teacher: So this book is
about the Constitution
and the reason...
>>Dejuan: It's pretty
awesome here.
My three favorite things are
math, writing and reading.
>>Sophia: It's kind of
cool so if you don't just--
aren't just with one
teacher and you get to kind
of move rooms and move teachers.
>>Jhett: When you
go down into the--
with Mr. Kirby in
your small group,
then it really stretches your
brain in a really good way.
>>Ashley: The teachers
organize themselves in a variety
of different ways and it depends
on teacher strengths
and students needs.
>>Student: Brushing
away the old vine.
>>Ashley: We may need a specific
group just on predicting.
And you don't have five kids
who need predicting in your 22.
You have a whole bunch of them
across the learning community.
So it's really important
that the tiers are connected.
Your core instruction
could be inferring.
If they're receiving Tier 1
with me and Tier 2 with you
and Tier 3 with someone else,
we all are really
teaching inferring.
We just may be teaching it
with different materials.
That requires a lot of
trust amongst teachers
and that also requires
teachers to communicate.
They meet every Wednesday
in a learning community
and they definitely check
in with each other
about instruction.
>>Teacher: Like had almost all
of their packet already filled
out and then there's
some groups of kids
that don't have anything
filled out.
>>Teacher: We have the same
problems with when they come
to us, they have to
finish up the packet.
So if we try to stick to
what that core part is...
>>Ashley: And then we meet
as a Student Success Team.
That team is made up of myself,
the learning community leader,
all of the core teachers,
administrators,
guidance counselors, speech
and language pathologists.
>>Lynda: All of those
stakeholders will sit
around the table together,
take a look at all of the data,
have deep conversations
about the effectiveness
of the core instruction and
also monitor the progress
of the Tier 2 groups
and the Tier 3
and then problem solve
together to figure out the ways
in which they might
make adjustments.
And then once they make
those major adjustments,
then they'll come back
together once a month
to make sure progress
is being made.
>>Teacher: And then reading,
which was mini lessons
45 percent of the time
and then 83 percent of the time.
And then you also had some
really other good details.
>>Teacher: Maybe her goal sheet
is almost like twice as long
so she has more space
like on Monday.
And right before you
go into Tier 2, okay,
what are the specific
things you're going to do.
>>Mindi: I think that
we're meeting the student's
needs better.
>>Holly: The growth that we see
in our students is phenomenal.
We've had kids go from
eighth percentile to thirty,
fortieth percentile
and sometimes higher.
>>Ashley: My work
is to make sure
that all kids get
what they need.
We have lots of different
types of learners
and everybody deserves
to have instruction
that meets their needs.
>>Holly: That was
beautiful, high five.